Amazon is doing another round of layoffs
9 000 employees will be let go primarily
in the cloud computing advertising human
resources and twitch units of Amazon
this is something big companies try to
avoid you do your layoffs once you say
hey it's already done you try to issue
calm so that your stock price will
remain stable but you say it's over
we're not going to need to do more well
Amazon is apparently needing to do more
this is not great in terms of how it
bodes for them and it raises more
questions about the shakiness of the
tech industry but for those who are
saying this is the proof that a
recession is coming maybe but you can
always find people saying we're a year
from a really bad recession eventually
there will be one that doesn't mean
their predictions were really
interesting incisive or anything more
than just idle speculation